un demi siècle après sa construction le
quartier de planoise va-t-il changer de
visage
les annonces de rénovation urbaine
laisse souvent perplexe celle ci
pourtant devrait changer la vie des
habitants
c'est l'intention du maire de besançon
la métamorphose passera par des
démolitions et les deux battements nasa
est menée avec la petite
sur cette vue de planoise les bâtiments
en rouge amené à disparaître plusieurs
grandes barres qui coupait la lumière au
total 1100 logements seront démolis
la vie a changé les besoins des gens
changer la composition des familles a
changé il ya aussi la pauvreté la
précarité qui est venu s'installer sur
le sur le secteur
il faut que tout ça soit revue et que
effectivement il y avait certainement
trop de 7 à l'époque un des des ruches
qui se termine en 1 passe maintenant
c'est que c'est pas très bon qu'en
pensent les habitants sur place beaucoup
attendaient ces changements mais des
bâtisses moins grand que surtout c'est
trop trop elles sont remplacées les gens
l'hiver c'est de le vent qui rentre
c'est le froid qui s'installe dans les
appartements au niveau des robinetteries
bon c'est tout un tas retrait il
faudrait que il faudrait que tout changé
et tout refaire ou les sols ces voix là
c'est des sols qui sont d'origine
pratiquement sur trois logements démolis
un seul sera reconstruit les urbanistes
veulent dédensifier le quartier et
surtout ajouté ce qui manquait dès la
conception de planoise au début des
années 70 une part d'habitat privé il
faut aussi qu'il y ait de la mixité
sociale
un certain nombre de 10 meur pour
peut-être vendu par par tranches pour
que ceux qui habitent puissent et
fonctionnement donc acheté ces logements
le budget total des travaux approche les
180 millions d'euros financés par
l'agglomération de besançon
les bailleurs sociaux et l'état les
travaux sont prévus jusqu'en 2029